the jurgen experience
so when did you get interested in the
subject
of ufos that happened at a surprisingly
early age i was seven years old
at a boarding school and the principal
of the school
a friend of his had photographed a video
an old reel the reel kodak movie camera
taken a movie
home movie of a video of a ufo
flying in beautiful blue skies
cumulus clouds huge golden
disc that that comes into the picture
and banks
goes into a cloud and it disappears into
this sort of wispy cloud in a way that
would be
very very hard i think to to fake
somehow particularly in those days
with no computer generated imagery and
it comes out the other side
and then sort of goes off over the
horizon and
i was you know stunned and flabbergasted
and
myself and all the other kids ran
outside that night and
were looking at the stars and it just
sparked my curiosity a lifelong
curiosity so once you got
into government and once you were i mean
you were there you're basically there
you had to start asking questions like
did you wait a while like how long did
you ask for your hey
what do you guys know yeah uh
well uh for a long time i waited um
very rarely i looked for openings i
looked for opportunities
so uh for example you know the stigma is
is so great that
you're reluctant obviously to uh to
raise that issue
a couple times there were some natural
opportunities
so uh one of my colleagues on the
intelligence committee
was going to hawaii for some oversight
trips meetings and he went to the maui
space optical tracking facility and i
said to them while you're there why
don't you just
check and see do they ever see anything
weird they can't explain and so forth
so he did and pete called me up and said
hey you wouldn't believe this i've got
this videotape here
and it shows these weird things and
so i talked to the air force people they
sent the tape to us
turns out it was totally unclassified um
i showed it to senator cohen
uh and some others and it ended up on
a national tv actually but
but didn't generate any further response
everybody just kind of threw their
hands up in the air and said well you
know that's interesting but
we don't know what to do with it it was
a ted koppel's nightline
show that this tape was played on it
showed sort of five objects
moving parallel to the ground possibly
in formation they're in the atmosphere
because they're
burning they're interacting with
something you know there's
plasma coming off them which wouldn't
presumably be happening in space
but they seem to be too slow to be
meteorites so it was mystifying and
difficult to explain
never did get an answer occasionally
something like that would happen
by and large the issue almost never
arose
the the issue is a weird issue because
if you bring it up in the wrong company
or at the wrong time you could be
dismissed
as a loon did you feel that when you
were there like
as a person who had a budding interest
in unidentified flying objects and and
what have you
did you feel like this is a politically
risky
thing to discuss especially to discuss
like in serious terms like
do you believe in these things like what
are they what do we know
is was that an issue absolutely um
i concealed my interest in the topic uh
for years
and uh very carefully and confided to a
few
trustworthy friends had a few
heart-to-heart talks with a couple
individuals
when i found a fellow traveler who was
interested in this topic but
by and large uh absolutely
uh wanted to conceal that and and not
reveal that
did you know clinton no no no he would
be the guy that i would go to
well there's a request that came to me
once
that i think was from president clinton
and it was one of the astronauts claimed
to have seen um
a ufo at edwards air force base and it
was videotaped he said
and he described this in his memoir and
wanted the president to get hold of the
tape of the video
and secretary cohen came back to the
pentagon from a meeting and
a message came down to me to go to try
to find this tape
and unfortunately there was
i got got nowhere with that the air
force was adamant that there was no such
tape there was no such information
anything they had on ufos have been
destroyed
so i had one of these situations that's
very common
in this area which is you have just two
apparently credible sources
but utterly conflicting irreconcilable
information
which seems to happen often in this
field now
being as you were in government and very
close to
literally the machine that runs the
world
what what's the general perception when
people are discussing
these these things in in washington
what is what's the general perception of
what what's going on with these things
i'm happy to say that it's changed that
perception has changed considerably in
the last few years people feel like they
have permission to talk about it when do
you think this happened
this happened after the new york times
article and
subsequent press beginning in 2017
december 2017
and um that sort of gave people
permission to talk about this and i've
actually had pentagon
friends who said you know this is kind
of cool we don't have to go in the
closet to talk about this anymore
what do you think kept it in the closet
before like when did the stigma start do
you think this was like intentionally
sort of set up this way it was uh
it was the robertson panel commission
1953 and they concluded during the
those cold war days that this was a a
potential threat to national security
because ufo reports might overwhelm our
our air defense and communication system
and that the soviets might
spook the public and somehow manipulate
this issue
so they actually advocated in writing
that
this issue be debunked and discredited
and the government uh went ahead and did
so
um extremely successfully unfortunately
and this all started with the project
blue book correct correct it was during
that era
so uh what was the gentleman's name that
was running project blue book again
um well there were different people
there's the guy who went on astronomer
ellen heineck heineck and heinek went on
to become a believer so he started
debunking and was told essentially the
way he reported it was that he was told
to kind of debunk
every single case everything he could
find whether it's swamp gas or
you know ball lightning find some way to
to explain this away but then once he
left
project blue book he started openly
discussing these cases and he started
discussing his own belief
that's correct and he felt badly burned
as well
because he was trying to carry out his
mandate
that the air force had given him as you
may recall in one instance he went to
michigan
and famously declared that the people of
michigan were misconstruing swamp gas
for for flying objects yeah and so
gerald ford who has represented that
district got incensed
as did the local population and congress
took a fleeting interest in the topic
and uh dr heineck was very embarrassed
um
and understandably so it was really uh
quite insulting to these to these people
who had
uh had very clear sightings of these
objects so
um he did eventually um change his view
publicly
and was very critical of of project blue
book
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience